yeah welcome to this blitz video playing
freedom master here from the u.s.
probably recording to the flag at least
he Neil and now let's see my Kings
Indian time normally play with 96 if I
play the Kings onion in those blitz
games it's usually the most entertaining
um Jeff 97 let this lie on and of course
I forgot how to how to play that g4 is
quite interesting trying to sort of keep
the Kings side closed and i think that's
Knight f6 saw King h8 so on so on a
possible way to play and try to to block
here make sure that the Queen side stays
closed yeah very difficult what what is
this Quincy eight now this probably just
night f2
a six intending be 5s probably mmm this
bed not sure he's playing the song in a
very ambitious manner maybe it's
perfectly all right at and don't know it
but with HH form yeah just dropping bag
okay that prepare b5 this completely
ridiculous I is probably playing her
before him and turn yeah nothing nothing
terribly wrong with that oh I can I have
f4 hmm add the bishop is a bit silly
here
night night only son be much better for
b5 takes takes before mm okay contiez
i'm preparing before himself
ok let's see me it's very hard to to
play this without b5 after playing
Bishop d7 I hope yet it's obviously a
bit dangerous but positionally dangerous
but hard too hard to play without it has
mentioned take Queenie 5 9 p-5 SI is
rather weak probably need to do that
what I'm hoping is that he's just
expanding just over expanding a bit d 5
so that dumb he's got weaknesses in this
camp because he moved so many pawns but
then objectively speaking this might be
rather good for white hmm yeah but now i
can take beef 5 but ok can capture so
but this you threatening something tween
87 for instances is a good idea maybe
going on the sensitive diagonal and yeah
okay I probably need to to open up the
position it so probably not possible to
play without that now try to double on
the fr well this is surprising I like to
go here
I cannot really take edge five I think
okay fade look sir look shaky maybe it
is playable but looks looks weird to
take I know g5 is a very very
double-edged move to staple to be a
positive about it because Nagi successor
is now possible after taking he gave me
a chive thus f4 and after checking is
giving me g 60 you just activated Wow
okay let's see what is playing now yeah
okay this is probably excellent her
black age 4 is hanging and F to gain
that
just attacking edge for always got b6
now be six is a good move okay let's
grab this first no yeah yeah this wins
the Queen yeah I would think it probably
was still still okay he needs to play b6
may be here okay it's already winning
for black home this was very risky this
g5 if he doesn't play g5 this is just
just very difficult to assess this
position it's some if white gets both
both pawns here that's him those pawns
are both weekend if he gets the boat
it's obviously good with the next report
i played this to get going on the f file
and now on he needs to play a natural
defensive move the the slight problem
with whites position is and i know that
from experience of the of playing wide
at the king's indian that's very often
you have you are really having a
substantial advantage but you have
weakened yourself look he's got all
pawns on the fourth-ranked or even here
on the fifth-ranked so there's no cover
of your your back area here the second
rank first rank third rank this is all
without port cover and if the pieces get
into the position on black pieces into
whites position it can easily backfire
or this it doesn't really matter then
that black has a bad bishop on g7 for
instance because the king is the problem
I think with the move like this maybe
was some other non committal move wyd
was certainly all right and after this
um night age 50 this is really the
computer gives black an instant win here
it's like minus three yeah yeah it's
simply
this is now on Andrew gave aid and it's
very hard to tolerate night f4 because
after night f4 takes eat eggs there's
also this bishop coming to life and at
the moment i'm also an opponent
temporarily at least that you also need
to get it back this also the upon so we
needed to grab this and after this
there's the next night coming yeah why
this is lost here you played this just
to quickly grabbing here here b6 was
better but the computer just wants to go
here and and claims blackest winning
yeah this age for how do you protect
that not at all and this is also a
thread now yeah he simply cannot take on
h5 and g5 for him as well I empty
absolutely must avoid to play a play g5
needs to keep those pawns where they are
as long as those parts don't move
black's pieces are rather passive rock
before is probably a good four wide yeah
thanks for watching interesting game